how did you get that where did you get
that why is your shirt older than my
boyfriend wait
wait Todd has never been on the earth at
the same time as Kurt Cobain
oh
oh my God I know she dressed for you
Esther's trying to eat you up we
literally ripped knees showing dirty
sneakers and then Hawaii 1999 Dairy
Queen tan look at your knees your knees
are like really well I feel like I've
never been paler
I feel pale am I not pale did you just
get back no I got back like three weeks
ago what wait wait a second can we just
break the fourth wall and say that we
haven't seen each other in so long yeah
I know I'm on the same page when did we
even film the one from last week so long
ago it was back it was I don't resonate
with November also I'm in shock too I
thought klyla got back in late last
night
she's like no I've been here for three
weeks no I've been here throughout this
um bomb Cyclone oh yeah yeah I haven't
missed any of the rain did anyone's uh
roofs Kevin oh I'll tell you what
happened
um till three in the morning trying to
pour water out of our balcony because
the balcony upstairs balcony rains got
clogged so we had a swimming pool up
there and then it was flooding into the
downstairs area so um Jules and I just
still three in the morning
like the old typhoon days in the
Philippines someone you can pay to do
that no we did all the emergency
plumbers were out so finally someone
came in at eight in the morning and was
like we'll save you I just woke up
yesterday to Dave being like Oh my God
and I was so mad because he always gets
mad at me when I wake him up just being
like hey he's like that's too much
energy in the morning and I'm like you
woke me up to screaming I was so serious
he needs to surrender too
because I've been together a decade
what's going on there is no surrender he
hates who you are who you are it's not
like ways you act it's like who you are
I know it has been crazy and you're
getting worse the things that he doesn't
like are growing also we in in during
the winter break he had covid what it's
backwards backwards
headbands with that bald head
well I'm not trying to be on the cover
of GQ right now but weirdly you could be
like this look is your best bet it's
very avant-garde for sure
wait what's cool oh my God wait what
were you saying I was gonna say that so
Dave got covered
um and then like he went home for
Hanukkah and then he he got covered and
then he came back so there was like five
to ten days or whatever where we were
living in the house together but
isolating and it was like the most fun
I've had it was so much fun to like wear
my mask and like meet him outside and
like sleep in separate rooms it was just
like oh that the tension You're Building
tension yeah burner and her husband does
have Apartments next to each other
Italian style yeah it kind of keeps the
Sexual Energy too I mean although to be
I think they live in the same one and
then they just have an extra one I think
so but that's like a Frida Kahlo and
Diego
um Diego Rivera they would have that
bridge that would connect their homes
again still I don't want to hit I don't
want to hit this again because we've all
heard it but
try to leave my vision
anywhere but he was cute the other day I
um where was as I I was getting a
massage and he was so it was like I was
my phone was off you know I wasn't
reachable and he's like where are you
where are you and I was like oh my God
I got all oiled up already and
um he's like just come home just come
home I get back and he had got me my he
got me the Air Max
uh headphones and so he had them there
and he was just like excited because
he's a spoiler
so he can't wait that extra week half
hour how do you like them because I have
to admit I've been all winter break like
low-key eyeing those I love that 50.
don't make a color they had to say how
much they cost no they're nice
um I got the black ones because I think
those are the ones that were available
but and he's scared to get me a
different color Carlos knows all the
prices of all the tech gadgets like he
has yeah
our next partner is athletic greens I
take ag1 by athletic greens literally
every day I gave ag1 a try because I
wanted better gut health increased
energy immune system support all of the
things if you're looking for an easier
way to take supplements athletic greens
is giving you a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to
athleticreens.com Tuesday that's
athleticreens.com Tuesday check it out
when it comes to personal hygiene who
has time to read that long list of
ingredients on the back of the bottle
definitely not me some ingredients I
can't even pronounce and if you are like
us and you care about what goes on your
body then it's time to try native
personal care products like we did every
native product is thoughtfully
formulated to keep you feeling and
smelling fresh all day long feel and
smell fresh this year with Native get 20
off your first order by going to
nativedeal.com trash Tuesday or use
promo code trash Tuesday at checkout
that's nativedeo.com trash Tuesday or
use promo code a trash Tuesday at
checkout for 20 off your first order
this episode is sponsored by rocket
money if your New Year's goals are to
manage your budget better and save money
you need rocket money stop throwing your
money away cancel unwanted subscriptions
and manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
that's rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
30 million women are impacted by weekend
or thinning hair and if you're among
them no you're not alone and that
there's a solution you can trust to
deliver results you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show by
going to neutrifold.com and entering the
promo code promo code trash to save 15
off your first month subscription this
is their best offer anywhere and it is
available only to us customers for
unlimited time plus free shipping on
every order get 15 off at nutrifold.com
spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
thank you to our sponsor liquid death
liquid death is some of the craziest
coolest funniest apparel out there and
they work with artists on limited
edition drops from the is it the severed
yeah handle hand that I have in my
right such a sick collab they dropped
with Martha Stewart so that was I feel
like all of our favorites you can find
liquid Death Mountain Water on Amazon or
at a retailer near you trash Tuesday
with Annie Esther and Kyla listeners get
20 off their first liquid death apparel
purchase available exclusively at
liquidath.com trash that's liquidath.com
trash
hi slugs happy New Year we're so excited
to be back with a fresh year of absolute
chaos and I'm back on the road I'm
finally coming to Florida you can see me
in West Palm Beach February 10th and
11th and in Miami April 21st and 22nd
and check out my solo Audio Only podcast
called my pleasure available wherever
you listen to podcasts this week I think
we talked about the 90s it was fun what
up sluggies so happy to be back I'm on
the road as always so excited I'm coming
to Madison Wisconsin January 27th and
28th I'll be in Dania Beach Florida
finally getting there February 3rd and
4th Washington DC February 24th and 25th
Seattle Washington March 10th and 11th
I'll be in Tampa Florida March 17th and
18th and come join me on anniewood I'm
there every Thursday it comes out on
YouTube I do a special morning wood live
chat with everybody at noon Pacific or
noon Eastern and 9 A.M Pacific it's so
fun come join me a whole another hour of
annual a week I'll see you guys there
wait Esther back to this shirt I did
think about you it's not the right size
for me I'm not saying I'm giving it to
you
but I really really like honored you in
that moment I was like I have to buy
this shirt because I feel like Esther
might splooge in her pants my mouth is
watering my panties are soaked like it's
so [ __ ] perfect the colors the 90s
aesthetic the fact that it's Dairy Queen
linked with Hawaii so it's like my basic
everyday life like combined with my
fantasy world how wise why is your
fantasy because you suck today I want to
bring it up again but you were the worst
person I've ever met there it was the
most disgusting thing I've ever seen you
brought the rain you brought a typhoid
there too [ __ ] a typhoon
typhoid fever is uh is uh yes she gave
that to Dave too that's a disease you
get you bring out a trust my brain the
right things are coming out it's a it's
a foodborne illness it's a look up
typhoid mirror what did I mean typhoon
typhoon
but you know what typhoons and typhoid
come from a very rampant in similar
countries in the Philippines typhoid is
still a problem in soar typhoon so
you're not far off but Annie you are
correct you're reminding me that Hawaii
is just a fantasy for me because the
reality of it I have terrible allergies
there and I can't go I feel like I think
we're still gonna blame the allergies I
don't think the allergies I mean I
believe that the allergies were real but
there's not a chance you were gonna have
fun also that's even not fun I think you
did have fun but you had your fun which
was sitting and watching the school
shooting
that's not bad here's Typhoid Mary I
think she was um she infected like a
hundred people are you serious they
found the person with typhoid fever damn
she was a hoe is that sexually
transplanted I know she was a cook and
she basically with unwashed hands gave
everyone pythoid that's why I don't cook
you're just generous
that reminds me of when I used to play
Settlers of Catan with my friends while
I had shingles and they would get mad at
me for scratching my shingles I'm like
it's not contagious like that don't
worry you look so young and act so like
you died 100 years ago
it's a fine line and it's not easy she
passed away of old age 100 years
um wait what does your shirt say oh it
says it's never too late to have a happy
childhood oh is it happy or sad what do
we think nothing sad I mean well
everything's said
no it's how did you feel when you bought
it by the way is it for a child it's the
size the sizes run smaller than I
thought
it's very tight is it a child's onesie
and you just cut the crotch out
you actually I should say this if I have
a baby this would fit them very nicely
that's how I feel about it I thought you
were pregnant with some of your tweets
recently really like which one you're
like should I get pregnant or sort of
Pinterest it was like she's pregnant no
no that truly was I said that to um
Carlos I was like she's got to be
pregnant really what did he say he said
nothing which I'm like oh that could
mean she's pregnant no no would you tell
him before three months
Carlos
I don't know no I gotta be a pre-90 day
person yeah okay yeah last time and look
what happened yeah look what you did
everyone has cute nails and I do want to
clarify these are so old no we don't
give her some cerebral palsy I like your
color oh no these are um homemade I
don't get my nails done like you guys
it's fine that's can I see yeah that's
cute thanks it's kind of like I really
thought it was gonna be a big [ __ ]
that's so funny I think I got like
bloody and like cuticles they're very
bisexual to me I'll just are they are
these are this color is bisexual yeah
and that length are we carrying this
through the new year
wait I do wonder that about you out here
today baiting's going through 2023. I
just it's that has nothing to do with
anything other than so here's what my
assessment of you is you tend to you
know desire
um girlies right but then I I realize
you always have coffin nails or really
long sharp nails so you don't intend on
fingering anyone you intend to be
fingered she wants to chop them up and
put them in a coffin
Esther's obsessed so you have no
intention of giving you are you want to
receive as a lesbian
um that's a really good question and I
will cross that bridge when I get to it
but I really just need I sometimes I
switch it up and have short nails but
this winter break I had like a weird
Christmas and I really needed Lana Del
Rey nails to like get me through what
happened during your Christmas I just
have like kind of had no Christmas it
was kind of like weird almost like you
were Jewish almost
I'm Jewish everyday but you know that
um we so how was your guys's breaks like
what the [ __ ] is going on I miss you I
haven't seen you guys in so long I know
Esther and I saw each other for two
seconds she brought me on stage and it
was like
I was almost annoyed that we were not
annoying I know I had a wonderful
experience but I was like because I
wanted it to be this moment we like ran
into each other here I totally agree I
know but it was so fun it was cool and I
even like I you put your stuff on the
floor and then I was like I was like
setting it on the stool for you but and
also Annie does this thing whenever I
bring her on stage at The Comedy Store
she always comes out before I introduce
her so like whenever at the end of my
set I'm always like a little scared and
like shaking because I'm like she's good
and then when I see her fear I want to
pounce it's my it's what's the opposite
of kryptonite it's like like I must move
towards it so I just came out and
started screaming
but how is how was your break look I
have no you were in like a different
country how long were we I don't know
when the last time I saw you guys
literally I was so thrown off by the
last episode I couldn't I was like what
you couldn't place it because like when
was this what are we talking about mine
was nice I was Gilbert got married in
Hawaii I spent my time there and then I
got back just in time for the bomb cycle
so Todd was born after Kurt Cobain he
was born in 1994. that's awesome Annie
high five it's my man five we found a
ring too
oh it's happening wait still pre-engage
this brings me to something that I
thought about in advance Oh I thought
you were gonna drop the I got married no
there was a tiny window where it was
maybe gonna happen because I was like I
like the year 2022 but then we couldn't
that was why literally yes
um that's the only reason because we
because it was like the 10 years but we
didn't you were like either let me [ __ ]
a girl
let's get married negotiations okay so I
have 2023 predictions for the trash
Tuesday crew for the three girls so I
predict one Annie is totally gonna get
married before me
I predict it I I think yeah that's an
easy one my kalila prediction is I think
that you're gonna get into some sort of
like love tryst with a really famous
athlete and he's gonna and he's gonna be
so obsessed with you you know in the
movie The Craft when the guy has the
spell and he's like too into her he's
gonna be like that to you and you're
kind of gonna be low-key about it like
you're not really gonna tell us but
we're all gonna be like what's going on
is there something there I have a
question about that yeah so if it's an
athlete in their Prime unless it's Tom
Brady or someone who's really gone
beyond their athletic years
um who can it be that's my age is it
going to be like a young guy your age
no okay so I'm dating a a younger
athlete unless it's like Roger Federer
he could be any age okay it could be
Demar Hamlin the one that just woke up
from the coma Beauty right is that what
he was in he wasn't in a coma but he was
intubated but he did die in front of all
of us that was Jesus the day I decided
to watch football I'm like I'm out
is that Dave and I are gonna go to a
strip club and it's gonna lead to him
having to have a serious talk with me
afterwards I love that even in your like
fantasy and predictions there's a talk
no these are not famous these are actual
things I believe
I really like this prediction is this um
athlete gonna is it gonna end badly am I
gonna be hurt like physically no I think
you're gonna be in the power position
the whole time and like he's you're just
you're gonna change his world and he's
gonna like just always love you make you
get a tattoo or something oh my God
Esther's gonna come in in a football
uniform
getting it always cut circles back to
something sick Dave has to sit you down
and be like why'd you dress up like this
he embarrassed me in front of the whole
writer's room it all goes down at your
wedding the predictions all happen I
have a lifelong prediction for you no
one is ever gonna physically hurt you
again you're done oh physically I don't
think anyone's gonna physically or
you're done the herding part's done yeah
I do I think you never know it's over
yeah especially if it's enough I'm a
witch sexually I don't think so oh you
mean like pull stretch it out oh I
thought you meant like fiscal abuse
I love it by yourself no I got I got an
SM necklace I don't know where I think I
left it at my other Studio but a sugar
mama necklace oh I like that I walked
into it also the biggest mall in Asia is
an SM oh really I think so yeah they
call it SM what is it what does that
stand for I don't know Supermarket super
supermarket you're my Supermarket okay
that's so cute thank you
um eat my ass like groceries yeah
I'm really proud of us we've gone what
20 minutes and no talk of sex it is a
new year indeed like that was the Booty
like groceries oh no we talked about
fingering yeah yeah [ __ ] why who cares
2023 for me I'm here's what I've learned
and it's very basic and everyone already
knows it but it's like people are gonna
like you people are gonna love you
people are gonna hate you I'm the only
way that I can't fail is if I'm just
true to who I am and that's that and I
think that's like the US three that's
such a thing that we have in common is
we are all so specifically ourselves
and we cannot we can't help to a fault
yeah but I think it's okay no it's not a
fault there's no Faults what did you
learn I learned something really
important ABC's I learned no I still
have to sing the whole thing I have to
sing a song I can't like jump I don't
remember what our next I don't know the
neighbors did you learn multiplication
and division no I learned that it's
never too late to have a happy childhood
that's the perfect roast thank you oh I
went on a I went to Costa Rica I did a
breath work yes trip there what yeah it
was really fun it was really cool I
didn't like explore Costa Rica at all I
went to Costa Rica when I was
um 17. when you went on that long yeah
trip and then and that was when I
had my first beef with sea turtles Right
vaginas
but
um so this is my first time going back
it was really it was cool but did you
take Todd with you no Todd doesn't isn't
in any of my hippie [ __ ] he doesn't like
my eye a lot he went by yourself yeah I
went by myself but I went with I have my
like breath work Shaman and then there
was a group of people and it was I have
so many shamans but
it was really cool I got to like really
I was like very much like tripping out
doing breath work like Ayahuasca level
did you do Ayahuasca there no I just
said breath work did you do any drugs no
no drugs only breath work and it was so
awesome and it really reset me and it
kind of is like in aligned with what you
were saying where it's just like really
not giving a [ __ ] with I kind of like
stepped into my zeusness like my
authority my like feeling of
uh self-trust and stuff like that but
anyway but so that was really good and
then I'm going to do Ayahuasca again
next week
where I'm going to uh Florida to do it
oh nice I just have a traveling shop and
I go wherever he is wait I'm so proud of
you that you went and you went to Costa
Rica without Todd I know I was really
nervous about it because I'm so used to
being like driven and care my stuff but
isn't this such a great feeling that's
similar to how I felt when I traveled to
Asia recently by myself it like I've
always like I need somebody I need some
comfort person I need some security
blanket God it's such a great feeling to
be like holy [ __ ] because it is the self
trust that I think I'm I'm missing a lot
where it's like we are so we
self-reliable and you kind of forget
that you are because you do like you
know we cohabitate with people we have
deep friendships with people but it's
like no like you're strong alone too and
also it's like I feel like when you
travel alone for me at least I was kind
of nervous I was like oh my God I was
like worrying about like am I gonna get
robbed all these things and then I was
like I don't want to even think about
that stuff like I don't want to go in
prepared or like you know going too
loose to another country but I also was
like I don't wanna I just want to trust
that everything's gonna work out I've
never not been robbed yeah I know I've
never not been Rob I've always been
robbed and one of the times I got robbed
I was skinny dipping um with a boy in
the ocean and they took everything
including including my clothes so they
even took the boy and we had to I had to
walk back I had to steal towels from one
that was like hanging oh now that
person's like I was wrong yeah so I had
to Rob
um and then I had to walk with a towel
back to my home how many people do you
think had been skinny dipped down the
line and had to steal clothes
[Music]
so you guys basically take ag1 every day
right I took it this morning I've been
taking all my supplements but I take my
my athletic greens is the easiest thing
to take it tastes so good I put it in
nice cold water before I go on my walk I
I love that they have travel packs
because for me like I like to bring it
on the road and just know I have that to
like keep me and it's easy because it's
one thing right like I'm not bringing a
bunch of [ __ ] I just have my athletic
greens and I know I'm like meeting my
daily nutritional needs that way after
I'm going to have them in all my
different suitcases and you can add them
to smoothies the way I drink it is I use
my matcha stir and I add a little bit of
ACV in it oh it's so good and that's it
I'm covered for the day I don't have to
worry about whether or not I'm getting
my greens later on that day I just feel
like I love it I just I've gotten almost
addicted to the taste of it it's really
like this weird sweetness and it's just
I don't know it's good it's really mild
tasting
and ag-1 has been a part of millions of
mornings since 2010 which is kind of
iconic and every scoop is packed with 75
vitamins minerals and Whole Food Source
ingredients so the highest quality that
give me major benefits like gut mood
support boosted energy and even
healthier looking skin hair and nails if
you're looking for an easier way to take
supplements athletic greens is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to athleticgreens.com
Tuesday that's athleticgreens.com
Tuesday check it out you guys it's that
time of year again to reassess our
personal hygiene you guys you know
native for their aluminum free deodorant
and Native keeps their ingredients list
bare naked with ingredients that you
actually understand like coconut oil
shea butter and baking soda
I do think it's so amazing because it
took two weeks for me to like not I had
to get all of like my stench out before
native started working for me which is
such a good Testament to it it's like
getting all these weird chemicals out of
you and then now it just smells really
good and yeah I think Native does a
really good job at um neutralizing my
body odor without
um having this like overwhelming
um
um scent to it I love the eucalyptus and
mint I love the lavender and Rose those
are my two go-to's and I'm an armpit
sweater I know Annie you are too and I
it's not that I I don't want to stop
sweating I just want to stop smelling
and Native really really does a job for
me I love that they're always dropping
limited edition flavors they have like a
collection of gummy bears strawberry and
vanilla Taffy sour Berry belt is my
personal favorite
um you guys feel and smell fresh this
year with Native get 20 off your first
order by going to nativedeo.com trash
Tuesday or use promo code trash Tuesday
at checkout that's nativedeo.com trash
Tuesday or use promo code trash Tuesday
at checkout for 20 off your first order
and what I also love about them is they
check a lot of boxes 72 hour odor
protection naturally derived ingredients
goes on smooth residue free like it's
just a great product I also really want
to just call you out on something
there's no way your favorite isn't
coming better it's a nice try
sour Berry belts
are you a skinny Dipper usually no
because my I don't like the way my my
tits fall when I stand
in the water just when I'm like this I
like them I like the way my boobs look
when you're standing regular not yeah
okay because the water they kind of in
the water it's great the water it always
looks great so maybe I'll do this and
then in the water I let my my boobs fall
my boobs are a little bit more separated
I have my boobs are wide set mine are
white set too so okay so we did breath
work in a river we did breath work in a
river like with snorkels and we we had
partners with snorkels with snorkels
like down in the water but I had a whole
rebirth thing it was so crazy I flipped
my ass around I'm no longer breach it's
never too late to come out the right way
but it was crazy I just learned a lot
about how your the way you're born
really will affect you and it sounds
like so stupid but it really makes sense
and it all kind of fell in line you know
I was in this incubator I was just I
felt I got to this like root of feeling
where I had this like shame inside me
that I didn't realize I just had this
shame and there was one point where
we're like sitting around a fire and I
was just started crying so hard and I
released this shame and then this lady
just [ __ ] hugged me it was like so
nice it made me feel better and she was
kind of like not a mean lady but like a
[ __ ] like in a fun way
so it was like very exciting that it was
her hugging me I was like oh the hard to
get [ __ ] hugging me
and then just like all the stuff with my
mom and just like it just helped me
release a lot of stuff it was really
cool but when we're in the river so you
sit and like help someone while they're
breathing and then they help you and so
no one drowns or floats down the river
and the current was like I was gonna
like kicking around this is crazy I know
but what I was going to say is while I
was sitting and holding these people
we're all like pretty white looking I
don't think anyone wasn't white looking
uh and then people just like walked by
and they're like people like working on
the river they were like doing something
on the river so there's like workmen
there like looking over us like they
must be like these [ __ ] white people
coming into our [ __ ] country and
doing breath work in our hot spring it
was a hot spring
but it was pretty funny and that you
would just see people go to like like
couples like other tourists come to like
want to sit in the hot spring and then
they'd see us and be like and I'm like
I don't want a part of this
were you in like a raft no you're just
like in the the water yeah I kind of
want to take you
um diving now because so much of diving
like is really all it's all breath work
I've been match I've been wanting to
smoke
bro I want to get on this heartbreak
again but we can start in a pool first
like just 10 feet and we can just
submerge and then stay in the bottom and
you learn to hold your breath
um and then you learn to breathe up but
breathing up is just as important as
holding your breath but it is so
releasing it is so like meditative
because your Force you cannot think of
anything but your breath like you just
cannot you physically you can't sit
there and be like gee I wonder there's
no G I wonder you're so focused just on
the air in your lungs and it takes you
out of any worries or concerns above the
water line yeah no I would love to do
that because I like Bland breath work is
fun too I was doing it today I did a
like an LED light bed
and I did this 44 breaths that my um
Shaman made I can put the link somewhere
it's online but um it's just really cool
just like it's a quick breath work it's
15 minutes but it's he leads you through
our meditation it's about a half an hour
but it's just you do like seven deep
breaths then you do two sets of seven
medium breaths and then you do three
sets of seven fast breaths and then you
do this part where you breathe in hold
your air
breathe out breathe in and then you exit
all your air out and you don't you just
stay in the exhale and that is like my
favorite thing so you really feel like
that works for me yes it's the best wow
so cool and now I'm going to do
Ayahuasca to be like see what else is
that going on but I feel so like Zen and
and good and I'm getting I'm doing a
bunch of things I'm getting ralphing
which I went to my first session of that
which I recommend for you
um probably for you if your neck injury
is real or not I can't tell
oh wait actually before we talk about
this I have a new exercise that I want
to pitch to you what I found out about I
think it's the perfect Esther exercise
okay it's called senior chair exercise I
love it my dad was like your mother and
I did a half an hour of senior chair
exercise as I go tell me more
and then I was here but I love the idea
of that can you look up a video of it I
already can picture it it's great it's a
fit the instructor's name is Esther go
to like the middle let's see what it is
it's like a young cool guy okay there's
one oh this is it hurts like you laugh
but this is like everyone should do this
every day I this is good stuff
wait I can I can I can
but this one is a little bit
we're not fully healed I have frozen
shoulder on my left oh God is it Elsa or
Anna
he has shoulders next and that actually
feels so good yes what if we find out
this is our thing it's so are you
kidding me I've been walking I've been
doing trying to do 10 000 steps so
that's usually like an hour and a half I
have so much foam over your guys's
breath success because
um one mine is obviously bad but that's
related okay because your facial
structure we can tell
um
we I just learned that your face
structure changes according to how you
melt yeah I saw the tick tock I know
it's humiliating I've known about mewing
for quite a while guys but I've been
doing yoga and I've been having like
such great success with it but the
breathing is still where I'm like very
about I think that's the hardest part
though like to
to kind of match your breath with your
movement is still the hardest part of
yoga for me okay because I'm panting
fully I'm exhausted especially if it's a
more active yoga and I'm like no I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna inhale and exhale
according to when they tell me because
I'm just trying to get you know so this
is why this is hard for you because you
probably do just need to do a lower
level one but you're like uh you're
hardcore no I can't breathe through my
nose so in yoga
um I have to mouth breathe because I
have nasal collapse so I have I have to
actively mouth breathe so I sound like a
[ __ ] dog they can't do anything for
your nasal claps they have to graft
something and like fix it because they
would have to like rebuild it kind of
apparently it happens to a lot of women
as they get older in your hormone
changes like it changes the shape of
this and it narrows it or it's something
oh you have old lady nose yeah lucky
Lester don't worry you have it too wait
so tell us more about yoga uh what kind
are you doing I don't know what it is I
just have been trying to be really
consistent with it and I noticed though
that the one thing that I'm not
progressing at is like any kind of
pairing the breathing with the movements
because I'm so focused on the movements
that like and it's funny I bet once that
clicks I'll be like oh this was so much
easier how long have you been doing it
um I do it like once a week probably for
the last like six months or something oh
consistently once a week yeah is that
not is that it's just very it was more
Esther than I thought it was I was like
okay I'm very proud are you doing it all
progress no I go you go to a class yeah
um and it's just a regular knot because
I'm quitting Hot Yoga I'm never going
it's not hot no yeah I I'm not I'm not
into hot yoga I want to generate my own
heat yeah I don't need to rely on I know
Esther's having a little hot yoga in her
pants
you guys you know that it's our 100th
episode it's our hungry episode that's
right like congrats congrats congrats is
that that's
more congratulations to Carlos that's a
hundred thousand one hundred right it is
no it's a hundred what is that number to
100. why are there two of them
[ __ ] it's just two 100s what the [ __ ]
Carlos first fight of the Year oh God
he's throwing stuff at us again here
I'll wear it
um donut went to it did we get that on
film when he was pelting us with things
we did okay I just want it for the
records
so since we've last convened there was
like a huge I feel like something that
took over the internet was this big
article about nepo babies
and we like haven't gotten a chance to
talk about it and I'm just curious like
if each of us were a nepo baby who would
our parents be who would it be and I
have I think
I already think that you would be
Britney Spears's cousin because I've
been out wearing hugs
ah I feel I would have been a nepo baby
of someone in the art world
because that's sort of Frida because of
that unibrow I kind of almost
um kind of a nepo baby like I grew up to
like an extremely rich father who's like
generational wealth on his side and
they're all artists from um from um
hotels some textiles oh my God she's
Paris Hilton's cousin
um but
um yeah they're just like old money yeah
if my dad didn't lose his [ __ ] it would
have kind of been like a a trust fund
baby
um I think to be a nepo baby it's more
like famous Hollywood yeah okay I was
thinking you might be like Billy Bob
Thornton's kid from like a first random
oh the bastard child yeah oh yeah yeah
Tyler of Billy Bob Thornton wait what is
that about because I love Tyler Steven
Tyler's daughter yeah and she would be
like because she's like yeah but the
live Tyler didn't grow up with Stephen
Tyler as right yeah Billy Bob's like
your dad and your mom it's kind of like
Rob Schneider and um and Elle King Elle
King right
there's right you're about to be a model
yeah you would have been raised by her
yeah and then Esther your mom wouldn't
have been a model
I already know I already know mine yours
is Dave Grohl right is that too hacky
because I already know there there's
another one let's be real I would be
Paul giamatti's daughter okay we all
know when he banged like before
um
sideways oh Sandra Oh no no wait no
that's hard in Bangor
that was the other guy who's the woman
in Nell
oh Lord you always bring this before
because you're now it's so funny how
you're not
in what movie it's Jody Foster before
she was gay oh I'll take you you would
be her like yeah her free lesbian okay
before she like came out when she was
still trying who would your parents be
like I yeah Nicole Smith no oh so cool
though somebody called me Annie Nicole
Smith last night because I was talking
about how we had to buy it out of jacket
but it was on sale and how upset I was
the Canada Annie Nicole Smith would
never buy a sale jacket I could see you
in the Anna Nicole Smith family
like a trailery like trailer Vicki Lynn
is that that was her real name like
Vicki Lynn Hogan oh you could be Hogan
yes that's exactly like Hulk Hogan
weirdly looks like my dad yeah I take
that one yeah I think you are a Brooke
Hogan yeah yeah okay okay
and that doesn't she seem like a cousin
of Britney Spears yes okay yes okay we
got there by the way I just have to
shout this out because we're talking
about Hulk Hogan but like a core memory
for me that will never leave my life is
when the Hulk Hogan sex tape leaked and
it is him like him uh having sex with
this woman and he's just talk while
having sex he's talking about how he's
so full and how he ate so much
did you relate to that me and Dave talk
about the Hulk Hogan sex tape like so
frequently it's such a like big part of
our life maybe you should take the sound
and make a sex tape thank you
well Gawker like he took Gawker down
right with that so I'm like scared to
even talk about it but do you think he
was more embarrassed about what he was
saying or the performance itself I have
to say that like whining about how full
you are during sex is not something you
want like what was he saying Esther tell
us via you know you do this with Dave
do your role play dude do you guys use
it and no it's just like whenever we eat
too much we're like I'm so full and then
we think about it because he's like oh
I'm so full that's it it's really just
that simple and that's how you know it's
magical because yeah it's so hot to [ __ ]
when you're full and then you can use
your gerd as lube it's [ __ ] puking a
little bit oh I really cannot feel horny
when my blood is shunting to my vital
digestive organs shunting yeah because
when you eat like the blood leaves your
periphery and it goes all in a lot of it
most of it goes into your gut because
the gut is working to digest your food
so it's like there's no blood going to
my [ __ ] when it's all going to my
stomach oh but also when I'm hungry too
I don't want to [ __ ] either you have to
be the right
I have to be satiated I don't like to be
hungry
that's a word isn't it satiated but I
said it cute yeah yeah you did
I'm standing by that I liked it I liked
it I I'm sorry I'm not talking about
what was the word shunted don't shunt me
don't shunt the way I said that and then
I was called Ashanti's little kid and
let's just say I'm saying in a different
way than it usually said I think that's
why you also feel cold after you eat
like I always kind of shiver after I eat
a huge meal because your blood is
leaving your periphery is that not true
am I making this up or did I learn the
wrong kind of science there no one here
I don't know Carlos is on Netflix right
now
we can see him watching Netflix can
someone enlighten me please because
that's always how I imagined it worked
um Also let's look at the definition of
shunt it could be multiple things you
can have a shunt that a lot of kids with
um fluid in their brain
um they have a shunt that goes straight
to their stomach okay so it yeah there's
shunting oh shunt is like a okay it's
like for if you have hydrocephalus right
yeah hide yourself I'm sorry did someone
learn a word that's right I know words
does someone learn one word she's up to
date with a medicine
the doctor now legally I used to think
that I'm like I used to ask my mom I'm
like do I have hydrocephalus or is my
head is naturally [ __ ] huge that's
for big headies and big headies big
headies
um
how do you guys feel about that
um study that um proves that women need
a lot more sleep than men
at night I think it's like not eight
hours for women they say like 10 hours
is what helps us regulate our hormones
and get the [ __ ] up and make me some
money isn't that so sweet it's a relief
for me I've always felt that I always
like look at guys who are such like up
and at them in the morning they just
like get up and go more so than me like
I have very low battery when I sleep
anything under like less than eight
hours and I'm like wait are you sure
eight hours is enough because ten feels
right I wish I had that because I
[ __ ] bust up I've been trying to like
force myself to sleep so that is
something about you I've always noticed
is like especially in the pandemic I
could be talking to you super late at
night and literally then like 7 A.M you
FaceTime me I'm like barely awake and
you're like hey what's up I met just got
my coffee like I'm like well I'm still
eating popcorn where does it come from
are you still like that I am still like
that I'm trying to like make myself
sleep because I don't want to burn out
you know but do you feel like you leap
deep the quality of your sleep is good
um I think if I tape my mouth shut I do
sleep deep but I [ __ ] it's really
hard to tape your mouth shut if I tape
my mouth shut I'm sleeping forever like
there's no eyes oh you die because of
your nose I'm gonna wake up dead because
your old lady knows yeah how many hours
do you sleep I found that like I'm very
consistently like I'm awesome after
eight and and I can't do any a minute
over eight and anything less than eight
I'm like a little bit weird what about
on your period
I think it's the same
my period really only affects me with
like that for day one of like crazy
crazy pain where I'm like just
completely [ __ ] over I need like
Vicodin or something if I have to do
like oh she's a drug girl now that's
right so I actually don't even know what
Vicodin is I'm just assuming it's the
same thing as hydrocodone I feel like
you'd hate Vicodin because they'll just
not make you [ __ ] well yeah constipation
makes you itchy too yeah itchy I think
it doesn't work for me for like pain
management I always think just like
um Tylenol with codeine works better
like T3 I
um was talking to my dad today I
facetimed with him and right before I
came to the show and he was like
I had just gotten my parents are getting
every vaccine it's so crazy I'm like
what are these vaccines they got these
they have to get their shingles yeah so
they got their shingles one and my dad's
like your mom's feeling fine I have a a
fever of 102 or something like it was
and he's like chat chat chat chat chat
and then he's like takes me downstairs
he's making jokes with my mom and he's
like I better get ice cream like he's
being like so funny and crazy and I'm
like Dad you're acting like really well
for someone with a fever and he goes
yeah well you know I start chatting and
I just like come to life and it's like
we're just exactly the same we're just
so social that's if we start like
talking we're fine
that's so so cool he's like when I'm not
on the he said when he wasn't on the
phone with me he was feeling like bad
and down like cute I wish I was I had
consistency like that because then
people know what to expect out of me
because sometimes I'm just like
energized and I can do a lot and then
other times I'm like nope yeah like coma
hibernation and very like I don't have
that same I think that's just like
bipolar yeah maybe
what um so you're bipolar too you said
um yeah that was the last diagnosis I
got when I was like much much younger
does it resonate with you
um it does like the depression part does
I don't have um Mania like that but I
definitely have the depression and I can
I I feel like I have no Mania I just
have normal times and then depressive
times
so I guess that's where the polls you're
waiting for your Kanye I really do it's
like give me some Mania I want to feel
something about me I'm I'm I match
people's Mania moments I want to be
manic I could I could use a little Mania
yeah I feel like I had this friend in
college who got diagnosed bipolar and
she never acted bipolar and then when
she got the diagnosis she started being
so bipolar oh but I always wonder if
that was like she got like permission to
stop having to act
away oh maybe or if she just [ __ ]
leaned in I don't know
or if she just I just didn't notice
those things before our first banana
break of 2023. I know any thoughts on
like how unripe the bananas are
How likely [ __ ] air one just eat it
oh my God
what I hate I'm so sorry I have a bone
to pick with arawan I'm doing a double
banana cheeks again
no keep going no keep it in your mouth
I'm sorry I do realize but like
arawan is a [ __ ] scam you guys of
course but beyond that it's like if
you're going to they have some good
smoothies soups are possible but this
one soup they had which is their just
chicken and vegetables the most
tasteless most Bland like it's like they
just don't know that salt or spices
exist it's my favorite one I get it
delivered to my house I like the split
pea soup I like all their soups and I
like their smoothies are okay but I do
end up for 35 dollars for just a jar
this big I don't think it's 35. it is
like my money yeah this is like my new
thing with air one is I go there I like
I think I was talking about this on
stage last night but like I go there to
be degraded and like charge me more
humiliate me with your prices like it's
part of the experience to just feel like
a little piece of [ __ ] when I was living
in my water you have a thing like glass
Euro on water
do you have the membership yeah yeah
I don't and they always like look at me
in a really judgy way when well they
should I'm like they're like yeah
because you're trash
[ __ ]
I'm gonna buy this one of us you know
what I'm gonna buy the soup for you and
you're gonna eat it in front of me I'll
[ __ ] slurp that whole thing down I
love that soup I made um I made two
crock pot stews
you guys can you cook easy with a crock
pot I decided to I'm not eating out
anymore because I was just getting so
fat I mean not fat to the world but fat
to me but crock-pocket bad as I've ever
been I know it's not bad dude [ __ ]
obese to me wait Annie I can relate to
that I think right now and I'm not
hating on myself at all but this is the
heaviest that I've ever been in a really
long time but I mean I'm not like
tripping out on it but the crock pot is
the perfect solution for you because you
can set and forget just chopped it and I
feel so accomplished I made this whole
[ __ ] stew and then the stew gets
better the more it's in the freezer and
the fridge we'll cook and I'm just
making sure that I eat the whole thing
like usually Todd and I will like have
these moments of like we're gonna make
crock pot stuff and then we eat one
serving then never have it again I'm
finishing the stews I'm enjoying I'm
using the new map give us a [ __ ]
sponsorship link us with a recipe this
sounds good oh the recipe is just I got
a bunch of vegetables I feel like
putting it in I put garlic cloves in I
put
um salt and chicken stock and I get
chicken thighs and I throw them in and
then later in the day you have
you know a meal for the next whatever
yeah three days I got this last time I
got marinated
um it was like in these Mexican
seasonings the chicken throw it in so
then that's just extra flavor they
[ __ ] did it for me I don't even have
to throw it in
chop some carrots I have so many great
crock pot easy easy recipes I'm down to
try I'm a crock pot [ __ ] Wow Let's be a
crock pot team like let's all be
crock-pots
own a crock pot I have an instapot is
that the same thing yeah
Well mine's like a faster it's faster
it's the pot is just like a pressure
cooker it's just a basically the same
thing but just because the pressure
cooker cooks and tenderizes things fast
faster okay and a crock pot for me is
like a slow cook you just set and then
six hours later you have this amazingly
that might be better because one time I
I've only used my insta pot once and
honestly the cleanup after like all the
little pieces
like best it's so easy to clean yeah
just one bowl and then it's also mine's
also an air fryer so it's like you just
take the air fryer part out and it's a
bunch of things but I do love it it's a
hot one J wolf sent it to me when I was
in harder times
and Jessica
yeah they're like salt and pepper they
never separ
um wow okay so crock pot goals actually
that you have fans on your instapot it's
so funny Jay Wolfe is our father yeah
he's our dad some of our fans we have
very close relationships Jay Wolfe was
helping me with like I thought you guys
were talking about Josh Wolf I was like
wow how charitable of him he would help
young Comics he would do that too Jay
wolf is a fan then he's one of our our
first family at this point yeah from
live stream the family
you too could go from fan to family
honestly if your New Year's goals are to
manage your money better you need rocket
money rocket money formerly known as
true bill is a personal finance app that
helps and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions that they forgot about
like the streaming service that you
randomly got over winter break that you
just used to watch one show and the free
trial ended and it's your life is
spiraling out of control and the Army
Hammer documentary is over so
rocket money makes canceling
subscriptions as easy as a click of a
button simply find the subscription you
don't want and press cancel and Rocket
money will cancel it for you no matter
long hold no no more long hold times
with customer service or tedious
emailing back and forth and an average
person saves 720 a year that's a lot of
money thousand dollars a year for me I
mean don't you guys feel like you have
so many subscriptions that you've just
lost track I just this actually just
helped me so much because I finally got
rid of my spray tan and my my hot yoga
subscriptions through it your Planet
Fitness or what was that no I had I
don't have a planet what crunch crunch
crunch oh yeah it was in Planet crunch
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday you guys
30 million people are impacted by
Weekend weakening hair I was definitely
one of those when I turned 30 my hair
just started falling off my head in
Rapid
very very concerning speed I'm in an
abusive relationship with my hair I I
fry it I diet I do it all so I
definitely feel like I'm starting over
with neutrophone not that I will stop
doing those things but I get a new
chance to do it I'll have all this new
hair growth I love neutrophils so much
it's so good I take my four pills every
day if I forget I feel like a piece of
well I put my hair through so much with
just constantly either being in the pool
or diving a lot and so I need that extra
support just for my hair and nails and
neutral this is why I believe in neutral
it's not an overnight fix it is
something that you take that I have
taken for the last two years maybe even
longer that has really just supported
what I feel is just like healthier skin
overall healthier nails and
my hair is back to being sort of you
know where it used to be again I'm so
like honored that they sponsor our show
because they are such the like biggest
best product I feel like over the last
10 years neutrophil is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
your hair growth thickness and visible
scalp coverage neutrophil supports
healthy hair growth from within which
clyllo's always teaching us about it
targets the five root causes of thinning
stress hormones environment nutrition
and Metabolism through whole body health
so like you always say it's not
overnight fit it's not overnight fix
it's like actually treating the real
issue neutrophil is a simple addition to
your daily routine just four pills a day
and you'll begin to experience thicker
stronger faster growing hair in three to
six months I am one of these people I
take four every day it is the bomb the
clinical study 86 percent of women
reported improved hair growth after six
months and 3 000 plus Top Doctors and
stylists recommend neutrophil as an
effective and high quality solution for
healthier hair and you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show by
going to neutrophil.com and entering the
promo code trash to save 15 off your
first month's subscription this is their
best offer anywhere and it is only
available to us customers for a limited
time plus free shipping on every order
get 15 off at nutrifold.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash and
I think the beginning of the year is a
perfect time to like have this be a
possible New Year's resolution just like
tackle your hair be consistent with it
and see what kind of results it's so
good it's so awesome and they have it
for boys too so yeah
[Music]
sweetest fans in Seattle and a lot of
people had gifts for us and I got these
warm cozy socks because I'm an older oh
I love them
yeah they're
wait what is and what and then that's a
banana bag for Amy and a bag and uh rich
[ __ ] candle I love this I genuinely
thought that was a face cream I almost
did this it does look like you can oh it
smells so good too taste it I did that
with didn't I tell you guys I did that
with a toothpaste I put the toothpaste
Oliver I squeezed it on my hand and
started rubbing it in
this is not the consistency and I was
like in line ordering food I'm like
it's so [ __ ] embarrassing there's
like nothing you can do except you're
like I just use toothpaste as a [ __ ]
moisturizer oh because you carry
toothpaste around no no no it was in
like I was waiting in line and they
remember when I got you guys the by the
way have you used the golden tongue
scraper I did but you know it's not
strong it's not it is a lighter scraping
yeah I'm glad I can be honest with you
because I was so excited about the gift
but throw it in the trash I don't know
when I give people gifts you deal with
it whatever you want it's yours from
then but I yeah I got my friend uh I
went to Vegas for New Year's I did Wise
Guys it was so fun people stayed so the
way that the shows were set up was
um
like I wasn't I was getting off stage at
11 10 which is such a [ __ ] [ __ ] tease
of a a new year show yeah we just didn't
think of it ahead of time or the club
didn't whatever no big deal but so I was
like all right why don't you guys just
if you want to stay like after the meet
and greet just like hang out in the
parking lot and we'll just watch the
fireworks they had fireworks that we
could see from the parking lot and we'll
just do the countdown out there so but
it was raining and I didn't realize that
so I'm doing the meet and greet and
stuff and I'm like sending people out
just like stand in the rain and when I
came out all these people had stayed in
their cars and then we all like kind of
Switched some people had umbrellas and
stuff and we did the countdown it was so
cute oh that was a really big storm New
Year's Eve yeah yeah
I we had like I was like I'm gonna go to
this party and then this party and then
I went nowhere I mean you don't want
nobody else and no one cared oh the
gender's invited you and you couldn't
make it is that what it was yeah I fully
had like a classic Esther stay at home
New Year's Eve that was a perfect New
Year's to stay home yeah it was good
also you don't have have to I don't feel
like it doesn't matter but you know I
love Vegas you know I love comedy I love
my fans it was so fun we went Todd and I
won so much money that weekend it was so
fun I feel like I know I sound crazy I
feel like I conquered slots like I know
how to win the most I know your dad
probably said this when you your mom was
rocking you to sleep
[Laughter]
but God damn do I have a thing and I
just know how to follow the fun and my
friend Andy Andrews was there but this
is why I was thinking about it because I
bought him he got a flight out off like
miles or something I was like come out
you got to come out because Doug stand
up was also doing a weekend there was
doing a show there so we're all staying
in The Plaza Hotel together I'm like
Andy you gotta come so he gets it he
gets a flight and I'm just like I'll get
you a hotel and he was like okay so I
get him a hotel and then when I get
there he's like I don't really want to
like my own hotel room so I just
forfeited the room and I started to be
like I paid for the [ __ ] around he
wanted to sleep on something he wanted
to like be around people so he just
stayed crashed in someone else's room
but then I was like you know what when I
do give gifts I don't give a f it's your
room if you want to Forfeit the [ __ ]
room is your room like I'm not gonna
what am I gonna be mad about it and then
I was thinking about the Selena Gomez
and the kidney and the [ __ ] kidney
that's Selena's kidney [ __ ] she can
[ __ ] treat what is oh because the
friend was mad at how is that really
true do we know that no oh okay that's
just like speculative basically that
their friendship
um started to suffer because Selena was
allegedly back to like unhealthy how old
is Selena Gomez I think she's almost 30
right okay so here's the thing think
about all the friends that you've had in
your life like some just especially in
that type of career and stuff it's like
your friends just naturally sometimes go
in and out so think about that in your
20s when you're giving an organ to
someone right it's like you may just
like slowly not be friends with them
anymore it's a good lesson that is it's
like I'm not going to give you half of
my filtration system if I know you might
squander that yeah so it's like maybe if
we're in our 40s and we're definitely
friends for good right then I also know
that maybe your lifestyle is not gonna
consist of you know Benders anymore
because like you just can't hang you
know you can't you you can't deal with
hangovers I might give you half of my
filtration system is it how much does it
affect the person who gives up the
kidney I think if you I'm not sure I'm
not sure but I imagine there's a reason
we have two and that's just people live
with one just fine but I mean that's
that's
the the organ that filters your blood to
get rid of toxins
you know I okay so maybe you'd be like
picky about donating or giving a kidney
kidney but like what do you want one as
for your collection
[Laughter]
like would you ever
swap organs with someone just like get
closer to them if we both have healthy
no no because you're I'm thinking about
it in a very like sciency way where it's
like my body is gonna reject it because
it's not my own so why would I go
through that someone so much and you
just like want to become one I think
that's like such an ultimate expression
of love I'm about to call Dave and make
him have that talk right now how about
you just eat their [ __ ] Esther no that
is
sick that's not true because you said
you would eat hot girl fecal transplant
yes I would hot girl should be the
person I'm in love with they're not in
love with the hot girl
Are We Now spinning this that was
hypothetical no I would I definitely
would eat hot girl [ __ ] and I have a
couple of people in mind whose [ __ ] I'm
after
um that's so funny you got to make sure
Esther doesn't go to the bathroom after
you
she's collecting samples you see her
she's plunging
Esther's drinking the plunger Annie she
intentionally breaks her own toilets in
her house and tells girls like roomy
like hey use that one and so they clog
it and then you collect the samples you
sick [ __ ] this is where you guys are
absolutely delusional if you don't think
I could just outright ask for it get it
you're crazy I don't know right now call
it right now and say would you give me a
call or leave your [ __ ] [ __ ] now
foreign
[Applause]
this would you guys not give I would
give my [ __ ] to anyone you wouldn't give
me your [ __ ] I'm not giving I would
throw it in your [ __ ] face
I'd have you wake up with your eye
you're like why can't I open my eyes
oh I do remember when Randy Randy would
eat his [ __ ] no oh I don't even do this
[ __ ] he was so happy Randy's cuter than
ever by the way can't be a better he
we've been through a lot of [ __ ]
blood for a second we had to switch his
food up but Randy's the best he's so
funny we've been bringing I've been
bringing him and Todd on the road with
me and life is perfect it's so good
but we were just having fun we were
[ __ ] playing slots I found out I love
Bingo I cried I liked Bingo somewhere
wait Bingo was the best I cried I was
like a new thing I like my life just it
just wins wins wins wins wins fun fun oh
in Vegas no but just no in life I
thought man old school Bingo wait
where'd you go Bingo they have Bingo
there's not in slots they have a bingo
room in Vegas with the Stampers yes we
have to have we have to honestly we
should just plug Bingo okay Bingo needs
to be
rebranded I will first of all I will go
to Vegas and play Bingo 100 me too can
we just go play slot guys trust me
they're just being Bingo just Bingo guys
don't want to win money it's crazy
because okay I feel like in 20 I know
this he wants to go I can I can feel
people fun we're going slots your wife
can [ __ ] come we'll get a babysitter
because he and uh Pete's wife and I had
a Vibe by the way oh what kind was just
pictures we were like we had a whole
thing I feel there's silently had to sit
there
he was in between us too I'm feeling a
collective need for like in-person group
Community Vibes and I think Bingo is
like the perfect activity to just like
get a bunch of people together have fun
it's it's like you get to sit down
there's not a ton of social pressure
because there's an activity okay what if
we do like that chair exercises first
yeah and then we earn the Bingo but it's
the Stampers like because you can do
that they have like the machines you can
do and it does it for you which is kind
of fun but you're not doing anything I
like to punch but the Stampers it's like
you have to like you have to really pay
attention and you feel like you did it
and you don't win a lot like I think the
most you win is like a hundred dollars
that's so fun
I won two thousand dollars like I left
with two thousand dollars of winnings I
think in total I won a little over three
thousand wow and Slots I played the new
Dune slot was the [ __ ] bomb I'm
actually reading Dune now hello
if you lean into Vegas and just let it
do what it wants to do it's everything
you will end up getting the education
that you need I walk into a casino and
I'm like I've arrived it's like a mall
with lighting
money no no no no no wait what's your
like Hotel spot what's your favorite I
like going to Fremont I think three
months more fun it's like the like old
Vegas it's not it's fun to go to the
wind and kind of ball out and be like
fancy fancy and get the crab legs at the
buffet but
I was born on Fremont there my mom was
pushing me out on that that dirt also
just that area is just so different now
yeah they have a lot of like just it's
it's cool now it's so when I was living
there it was not great but the slots
that's in Cirque are the best at Circa
and then but I don't care I'll stay
anywhere but it was just the Karate Kid
One
um Little Shop of Horrors always it's
just and I it was things like I would
have like a vision I'm like all right
this machine Todd and I will like go
test them all I'm like is this the right
one and we're not getting Good Vibes and
like the first night at the the
um
this is so boring I already talked about
this on anniewood too sorry guys I'm not
going to double you up with these things
but watch Annie what if you want to hear
more about the slot
I go into depth there sorry but anyway
it's so funny and me and Andy Andrews
like I I couldn't sleep I made so much
money I could not sleep I was like just
wide awake just smiling like
so happy Todd was like tossing and
turning because he can sense when I'm
awake and um
Randy was there and then I got a text
from my friend Andy and he's like he's
like what are you doing it was 8 A.M I
was like haven't slept let's go and I
just put my hair in a ponytail and we
just went to the slots and we were just
they have like love seats you know where
you can sit with some we were just
laughing and it's like karate it's like
there's like things from your childhood
and memories it's just so fun you know
um
um one of my greatest memories was um
one time before I went to go to Vegas I
went to Petco to get dog food and on the
side and my periphery I see the sun
conure it's kind of like this parrot and
the sun conure was like calling to me so
I approached the cage and this thing was
just rubbing up on me like the sweetest
thing and I could not believe like how
much of my attention it wanted and I
walked out of there crying because the
sun conure caused it was like 500
something and I was like I really want
to just free this bird like I think it
really wants out and then I left for
Vegas that night and that night I won a
thousand dollars and the next day I came
home and I bought the sun conure and we
named them Rasta Oh I thought you're
gonna say you freed it I was like so you
have had a manic no
um but Rasta moved to because I was
dating someone at that time he moved to
um Texas with um his father oh so I lost
custody the universe gave you
technically because he won the money I
was with him
and then I was like we gotta go get this
bird and we came back and he was like
okay and then we named the roster and
then he went to go live with his dad
when he moved back to Austin did you
like um being a bird owner loved it it
was potty trained go poop Rasta and
right on top of the trash Rasta would
cuddle so your favorite thing about him
that I see was he pooped oh stop acting
you weren't you about to call your
[ __ ] these are Esther these are
flockbirds they're more affectionate
than dogs what they cuddle they sleep
with you like feet up like this
yeah they sleep with me so cute I have
to say my favorite Vegas activities
because I'm very big on like
non-traditional Vegas it like the most
fun I've ever had in Vegas is when we
went to this like really like an exotic
pet store and like got to touch and meet
head hedgehogs and like ferrets Little
Critters like that was very fun did they
put you in a cage and think you were one
of them yeah I did have to spend I had
an overnight stay there I rescued Fair
carrots when I lived in Vegas you
rescued them from where yeah they were
like really shitty owners and I
inherited them when they were really old
and at the end of their life there was
latte Frisco and um Rusty I had three
ferrets they were really cute such a
cute name
carrot was one of them no it was a
ferret I read the Pharisees that is a
cute name
I think that as a group or I know Annie
would enjoy this but I think we should
go see Usher yes I want to see Usher
Usher okay you know what I actually
already previously had had plans to see
Usher but they fell through okay I will
who are they with a friend
a special friend
um I was a special friend I know that
she's got another lesbian she's into no
me and Miranda we were gonna go but we
ended up not doing anything more
important to do probably
I really would have my feelings slightly
hurt though if you lazied out with
someone else before me I think
oh like like yeah notice
so have we talked about this no there's
like multiple lawsuits
that they don't fade
and it's true they don't fade it's been
it's only gotten darker it's actually
been like a year and three months and
there's no signs of fading
and Dave will be like are you gonna you
should sue and I'm like I'm good so when
listen when Esther doesn't want to sue
that I should sue what's happening yeah
you said a freaking year
I want it gone
I wanna yeah no I think everything in
Vegas is fun I've never not had fun in
Vegas even when I like wasn't gambling I
would go and because I don't drink I
would tell myself like all right you can
have as much cake as you want but then I
was just like had like a cupcake weekend
like I've never not had fun in Vegas I
can find it out of the out of the casino
in the casino all of it but I think we
should do a group bingo are we inviting
fans to do it
some podcasts they tour they do shows
live on stage we're just having a bingo
kind of fun yeah just in our hotel room
no I think we could literally rent out a
theater bingo
I'm down okay I'm down that sounds so
fun if anyone that I was a fan of did
that I would never sign up for anything
imagine if you just went on the road but
we took Bingo night on the road right
that's it let us know guys what the
appetite is either way we are doing it
though I was like CR I was like I felt
so like I've been really trying to like
listen to myself and and when I feel
something just really go with all the
goodness of the feelings
um I was weeping and I was like I can't
believe there's a footage of me being
like I love Bingo I can't believe
there's another thing I [ __ ] love I
didn't know about especially in [ __ ]
Vegas what the hell
yeah it's no secret by now right if
you've seen these beautiful tall boys
they come in different flavors as well
there's severed lime there's a mango one
um you know by now that this is our
water of choice and it's called liquid
death and just having it in my hand
makes me feel exponentially cooler I
feel like I'm drinking with you guys but
I'm not I'm just hydrating and we're
thankful for that all of us well we
remember the belly button incident
Esther we're thankful you as well
that was the highlight of last year
um it's called liquid death because
death to plastic okay and also this
branding actually will make you look
like you're drinking something crazy
that is death but it's just water so you
can trick everyone and be cute and cool
and I recently saw a guy got pulled over
because he was drinking one of these and
the cop was like oh sorry and it's
murdering your thirst brutally brutally
murdering your thirst
it's stabbing my thirst take my thirst
you can find liquid Death Mountain Water
on Amazon or at any retailer near you
trash Tuesday with Annie Esther and
kalila listeners get 20 off their first
liquid death apparel purchase available
exclusively at liquidat.com trash that's
liquid death.com trash
since oddly therapeutic I know the
fisting of the toy yeah but you get to
pet it and it's so soft you've never
looked crazier with the thing on your
head
I like you like this that's right for me
yeah because she knows she can get in
[Laughter]
get her when she's in an episode you
guys want some presents from Pete for
100 episodes yes please Predator Pete no
you know what else changed my brain
chemistry over winter break was learning
that Lana Del Rey has a billboard for
her new album only in her ex's Hometown
so good such a great move
yay Papa Pete thank you oh my goodness
this is so good okay
yeah all right for Annie uh you get to
reclaim something that you uh we're
after
for a long time
[Laughter]
how's that pod never forget never forget
by the way I'm just kidding I hope their
podcast is doing I'm still in favor of
just changing our name back and yeah
yours is a little manifestation and he's
gonna steal this truly my first crush
Legends of the Fall that says poster
America is just to replace Bobby behind
me yes cover it let's get rid of Bobby
no keep keep him get rid of his ass and
then Pete what is this it's just one fin
yeah well scuba equipment is really
expensive
so we'll have to do it in uh in chunks
ask her the other one oh my God Pete is
this
strawberry rhubarb pie it is
and then Carlos's gift is he's not gonna
make you eat it take it away
[Music]
it smells so good
where's it from Pete yeah a place called
the Republic of Thai and coffee in North
I know where that is oh yeah that's a
great place they have such good pie also
um rhubarb makes me [ __ ] my brains out
so if you take Vicodin take a little
rhubarb with it
oh we'll be right
did you make this
I did
is that like it's movie grade blood and
water incredible and
not it won't stain I love fake blood
it's my favorite I do I do miss I I will
say I do miss the old name I know I
still have people who call it that like
especially on the road we met people who
were like we were watching since
bloodbath I'm like oh I made me sad yeah
it's no weird thing that
yeah okay isn't it a weird thing that
every other podcast has 50 names are we
sure that we can
I'm not sure and I'm saying we should
just change it back why don't we just
know can someone who's a fan of this
show who knows yeah can someone just
like figure this out legally dear Kim
Kardashian you're a lawyer now can you
why are we the only ones that have ever
changed our name ever ever anyone ever I
just learned that
um I don't know how real this is but an
Insider person who works for cruise
ships says that they dose their food
with some kind of like laxative agent so
that people have softer poo so they
don't clog the toilets on the ship
that's amazing I wish every place did
that you imagine being [ __ ]
constipated on a cruise
to put extra fat which can have a
laxative is to make sure all the ship's
Plumbing works I don't know if it's the
fat I there I don't know if it's extra
fatty or they actually add something
but yeah the crews that I went on the
heavy metal Cruise what's up Papa Roach
how were the how was the plumbing on
that one the plumbing was fine I just uh
I will say that
um it's a buffet style where you can
just order all you can eat and
um I did not stop eating I was so full I
had bombs so I was soothing myself I
can't believe I know someone who went on
a heavy metal Cruise shiprocked wow is
that what is it called shiprocked and it
was so fun even though I ate it and then
I ate all the food too and now I'm
friends with Papa Roach but see I only
trust people who um have had have had
real Buffet experience because Buffet
used to be an Olympic sport for me and
my family like especially in my early
20s we knew all the good Vegas buffets
and if you didn't treat it like if you
were somebody that didn't get your
money's worth and sometimes it would be
like 40 50 bucks like I just had no
respect for you I've never a lot of
people well wait can I ask you as a
question I've never asked you guys this
how do you get your uh steaks cooked
um pretty bloody
not that way like
medium full or whatever you use a medium
rare you're medium well medium well I'm
not a state girl at all like like a
hamburger how would you get it cooked
medium full medium low Yeah Yeah medium
well
or whatever they do they don't even ask
you that at Shake Shack they're just
right yeah what about you
I get that [ __ ] as bloody as I can yeah
I like it the way you like it I like it
if it's a little cold on the inside I'm
like although I will say this I feel
like back in the day I used to always
make a point to ask for my Whopper
Junior like flame broiled because
sometimes they don't do it if you don't
specify have you been taken out to
dinner ever or that's a really good
question and the answer might be no
should we go to a steakhouse I'd love to
let's go to a steakhouse together okay
which one let's go let's go these are a
couple I like Ocean Prime on what do we
order we do what do you get steak I'm
more of a side Queen there's amazing
sides we should go to we should get like
one of those tables on the ocean at
Ocean Prime to celebrate 100 episodes
yeah okay I'm down first Carlos's dad is
paying will you call him will you call
my daddy for me ask him
no he's in the office right now what
kind of surgery
cancer in women
he's taking the out of the booby
out of anywhere
but only on women yeah
he takes tumors out of like obese women
a lot and I just tell you how weird this
is okay you are starting to remind me of
my friend Elliot whose dad is a
gynecologist I think like
boys with dads who are around like
vaginal areas a lot are you're a thing
really yeah you're like him it's like
because I ignored all this stuff my dad
did Growing Up So it's too gross like
all the pictures were so gross well
because it's problem areas yeah you saw
them as problem areas yeah I saw like
blood and tumors and just but you don't
care about a bloody [ __ ] hell no no no
there's no way I know just from when you
were just her companion on that Hawaii
trip she's just bleeding out on the bed
oh yeah I did oh my God you guys I went
to Hot Yoga and I got my period one
second before the class like you know
when they're like you know and they're
like they're like all right class that's
it last second and you're gonna miss the
[ __ ] class so I just had to free
bleed out in the hot yoga class when I
was wearing black pants always fun did
it leak out it didn't leak out but it
was just like the whole time like you're
having trouble attaching your breath to
the movements imagine you're like is
there blood gushing out of me right now
gosh I just can't imagine doing hot yoga
while hemorrhaging no and yeah that just
seems like a perfect a recipe for me to
pass out and that was the last class of
how yoga I'll ever do
it triggers my um it triggers my TMJ and
my uh my cluster headaches oh I want to
tell you guys about Ralph Ralph and real
quick it's r-o-l-f Rolfing and it's like
a type of deep fascia massage where they
they're working to like make your body
structurally back to where it was
supposed to be and I went to one [ __ ]
session and my jaw all day yesterday was
like sitting the way it's supposed to
sit to the point where I could feel
where these teeth weren't touching more
because it was like I've been grinding
those in and it was the craziest he
found all the points and he's like he's
like I'm just trying to learn what's
going on and find like the story of how
my body got into the way it is but it's
[ __ ] crazy wait I want to try that
have you have you tried frothing
frisbee golf
no anyone else do that in gym class get
out of doing the hard stuff if that's
the real thing yeah first big golf is
totally I feel like everything's a real
thing now like competitive juggling is
if everything is real then that means
nothing is real it's not a great that's
true yeah that's not why is that great
not great uh everything being real
nothing being real is pretty good to me
because then it's like what do we have
joy happiness whatever we want where did
you go ralphing I want to copy you it's
this guy I went to this guy I found when
I was on my breath work trip one of my
friends that I made on the trip this
girl Alex was uh she's a ralpher in
Florida and so she sent me to this guy
who is one of like the best
his name is Jan sultan
I love that I feel like I am obsessed
with my PT guy and uh
uh I fell in love with the PT guy once I
feel like he's handsome but like there's
no attraction there between us but he's
just so good with his hands yeah I have
a frozen shoulder it's been that way
it's gonna take like two years to get
better basically
um but he gets in my neck in places that
makes my eyes roll back yeah his name's
Lou Jay and he is just incredible and I
don't miss a session because he just he
just knows the spots on my shoulders
some people just have the touch no and
they just know and they know where to go
from there to like it was I had been
having so much pain I went and got like
a 90 minute massage from a woman and it
was great but it wasn't what I just
remembered something what I got one of
the best massages I've ever had in my
life from a place I randomly walked into
in Koreatown while waiting to um eat at
a restaurant that was like really packed
I was like oh I'm just gonna burn time
walk into this place called I think the
name was soya I thought I was going to
get my kidneys like stolen there I was
like oh this is where my life ends but I
was like I'm Gonna Roll the Dice going
to take a chance I walk in there and it
was like a husband wife team and they
didn't speak English the best hands I've
ever had both of them do it at the same
time no but a friend of mine got it and
I was like was the husband good he was
like incredible
incredible this tiny little place in
Koreatown I love it it's like I love
when like you just don't look anything
up on the Internet don't look for
reviews you just take a chance and it's
the best that is so scary to me like I
feel like that is where I get into
really bad situations well don't you go
late at night I've made that mistake but
that's like when I want a massage that's
the problem is I only want it late at
night like after my set yeah I'm like so
one of these days I'm gonna go to like a
[ __ ] place and just be like I've gone
I can show you where they are I've gone
accidentally and then realized like oh
my God there's this is a [ __ ] please
and I there was one place I went to in
New York that was like 24-hour massage
my friend
uh my friend and I were like we just
gotten Sushi or something and then I
don't know we're out [ __ ] around and
it was like 11 p.m so we were like it
says like 24 hours so we like knock and
then we see a light turn on and we'd
like welcome these people up like they
just lay sleeping next to the door in
case I was like we're sorry we're sorry
twenty dollars we're not getting a
massage sorry it's like I mean even
though it's their choice to have that
business but right like I don't want to
wake someone up and make them force them
to massage me is that because that's
what you do at home with Todd Todd I do
wake him you're right no he doesn't get
to go to sleep until I've been messed up
I have um one of my old friends like a
friend in the family he does a lot of
like undercover stuff in LA and a lot of
his busts involves him having to almost
get that massage
and so there's been many times where
he's just been in that position and then
he's like oh one second then he goes to
the bathroom tells like hey they are
that place and then they bust him but
when they bust him he still has to
pretend
um he does he cannot like reveal himself
he still has to be a John and he gets
jerked off no no so the woman's like oh
God like the cops are here here and she
tries to like hide him and he has to
play along oh my God yeah but one time
most cops get the hand job and then
arrest them I feel like that's actually
a very serious issue in the United
States um no not him because he's like
such a straight edge like dude he's also
just doesn't like being touched at all
and he's also like I don't know he just
is one of those guys that's just like
why do I have to do this but he's very
believable and so he does I was getting
a massage once and
um what is it called the okay so I was
getting a massage once in New York and
the woman barely spoke English and in
the middle of massage they called her
out and then I could hear her getting
interviewed by a government official
like testing her on like her American
all of the knowledge she had no way it
was so crazy it was during my massage
and let me tell you she did a lot better
than me on that test I was like I would
fail this I would fail this send me home
send me back to my country where would
you get deported to you think where
would I get deported to probably Russia
throw me right in you take care of her I
feel like of anyone you would survive
Russia the best I could I feel like you
would be the next Putin I could put in
my way through life I would actually
loved they just Deport me to Finland I
think that's probably the best way for
my story to end finland's a great
country yeah no I don't get to go to
Finland why not I'm happy
I don't want to go to Israel like
there'll be too many people like me
there I feel like I don't have any of
the finished oh they're like in the
military they're not like you at all
they're way better than you they're
they're practical they have skills
that's true you're not wrong no I want
to go to Israel Israel would be cool to
visit though yeah I would like to go to
I want to go everywhere I really wanted
to cut off for a Birthright I think it's
25. ah did you hear about Gwen Stefani
getting in trouble yeah I didn't see
that I was saying she's Japanese I think
she was just saying like a lie I don't
think she said I'm Japanese she just was
like
ah I guess I'm dropping like I think she
was just kidding but who knows it's so
stupid
you guys everybody is wrong everybody's
wrong like you're you're gonna say some
should you only need to dig so deep I'm
just saying true to myself and I'm
having fun and I don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I agree that's what this year is
about baby and everyone I know is
thriving so
you're welcome you get to have the good
luck everyone around
happy 100 you guys yeah 100 and thank
you to the Slugs for getting us all the
way to 100 episodes we wouldn't have
been able to do it without you
we have confetti cannons if you want to
use them
thank you how does it work again
you twist the bottom do I have one do I
have to open this or no no okay I won't
shoot it out you guys wait can I just
say something that the show is missing
what that we need to bring back
we need Esther to be very upset
screaming and running out of the room I
know you're comfortable here but we need
to I'm fully in support of that we need
to start bringing gross things for
Esther and we need to start overcoming
fears again
foreign
dude I'm scared somebody hold me I know
I was loud
talking I can't hear her oh my God okay
did I blow your [ __ ] ears yeah wild
but that's okay you guys thank you so
much for listening who bought them it's
okay ask me sorry
I can't hear [ __ ] you guys thank you so
much for listening and we are excited
for another 100 with you and we'll see
you next week with an all new episode
foreign
[Music]